devyn in Tampa starts off this hour hey
Devin how are you you Dave better than I
deserve what's up awesome alright so I'm
in a bit of a pickle right now I'm 22
and so let me just tell you this story
so long story short I thought I had gap
insurance in my previous our it was al
exercise 250 I got completely butchered
on them on the my interest rate when I
bought it
pretty much valuing it has 21,000 and it
was really only a $14,000 car anyways
long story short I didn't have gap I got
into a car accident I didn't get paid
out for the full amount so I still owe
4500 the issue is now is I also have a
closed credit card which affect my
credit score significantly so I can't
really get approved for many loans so
I'm trying to get that's awesome right
from you on what I should be doing I
think it's awesome that you can't get
approved for any more loans because you
pretty swell suck at this every time you
touched debt you really blew it up
didn't you seriously all kidding aside
and it ain't working dude stop it so
what do you make you living with
roommates or at home or what yes so
actually when I had good trade before
the credit card closed I did buy a home
about two years ago and what I do is I
just rent the rooms out and I live there
so I don't pay any mortgage no utilities
everything so okay that's good good
there's somebody everybody pays that
works out good and you're 22 and you
make fifty four thousand yes and you
don't have a dime I do actually have I
have four grand and I owe four grin on
that previous car so perfect do you have
a phone no I don't that's the issue I
don't have a call right now okay bye
five oh I have five days to pay off the
Lexus financial that loan or I want that
to the credit or one or it hits my
credit oh well
you ain't getting credit anyway you
ain't getting credit anyone yeah your
credit sucked right yeah I believe it's
580 yeah gave me a option I was asking
you I they give me an option to do a
payment plan with them which would be
over my previous payments it would be it
has to be over $350 a month I'd be off
of that that'd be great as long as they
don't report on your credit that'd be
great I
okay stop stop stop listen listen listen
listen let's just follow this through
okay let's blow this through carefully
number one we're gonna write a check and
buy a car probably really about 3,000
because I want you to have at least a
thousand dollars in your account all
right okay then you have one debt to
your name is that correct yeah yeah
other than the credit card yet
oh I'm sorry how much credit card debt
is there now it's it's three K and I
have a payment plan I said it with what
Fargo okay let's stop and let's listen
to this you have four thousand five
hundred and three is seven thousand five
hundred you make $54,000 a year you have
zero housing cost
mm-hmm you need to be on a budget and
stay out of the bars on the weekend
right okay okay you're partying and
spending all your money and you're broke
you can clear seven grand in no time
you're bringing home four five forty
five hundred forty two hundred forty
three hundred a month aren't you yeah so
how much of that can we put on this debt
let's say it was two thousand you'd be
debt-free in four months credit card and
Alexis is out of your life you got to
paid for three thousand dollar car then
we build an emergency fund of three to
six months of expenses you're sitting
there with 10 12 grand in the bank at
that point only for emergencies because
you've seen some emergencies so you know
you need this then once that's there
then we're gonna save up and move up in
car cuz you're driving a piece of crap
at this point right right yeah yeah you
gonna do this yeah yeah absolutely four
months you're debt-free six months
you've got money in the bank nine months
you're paying cash for a better car a
year from today your life is going to
look completely different
you
be driving a $10,000 paid for car you're
gonna have zero debt and $12,000 in the
bank one year from the day if you follow
what I'm teaching you yep and they'll
get the stress out of your life man but
you're gonna have to concentrate and
focus every one of those dollars on
those goals and not on a bunch of other
goals you got one thing to do dude
debt-free build your emergency fund pay
cash for your car put stupid lexus
credit keys on a payment for the gap and
then never do that again
never do it again learn your lesson you
will never need gap insurance again you
know why you will never have a car
payment again if you get rid of car
payments you have a real shot at
building wealth you're a hustler man I'm
not in a bad sense I mean you know how
to hustle and grind you're out there
pushing things around you got a lot of
energy you got 63 ideas going in this
one conversation
you know you've just been really
impulsive and disorganized so now it's
time to just grow up and fine-tune this
and you can do it and if you're 52 or
you're 22 the advice is the same it's
not an age thing so you can do this you
can do this hold on I'm gonna give you a
copy of the book the Total Money
Makeover and show you exactly step by
step point by point what to do and how
to do it then I'll walk you through what
we were talking about here you can do
this